[Musique]
ça fait bien des mois qu'on est
conscient de pose de police chinoise à
travers le pays et on est en train de
s'assurer que la GRC est en train de
faire des suivis là-dessus et que nos
systèmes de renseignement prennent ça au
sérieux c'est c'est un enjeu qui nous
préoccupe énormément et ça souligne à
quel point les
cibles primaires des de l'ingérence
étrangère c'est justement les
communautés de diasporel les communautés
d'origine chinoise iraniennes qui sont
ici au Canada
je ne peux pas croire qu'un premier
ministre ne reçoivent pas des breffage
des services de sécurité sur une base
extrêmement régulière surtout un pays du
G7 et un pays membres de l'OTAN je ne
crois pas à l'argument de lignorance il
y aura beau le répéter tant qu'il voudra
il y a des choses que le premier
ministre devait savoir et s'il ne le
savait pas il se disqualifie lui-même
le chef du Bloc quand il parle de
l'ignorance de Monsieur Trudeau ne fait
pas référence au poste de police mais
aux tentatives de
d'obstruer le bon fonctionnement de la
du des élections au Canada mais on
baigne dans tout ça premier tour de
table Michel David
cette enquête de la GRC qu'est-ce que ça
vient ajouter à l'histoire aujourd'hui
Michel
moi ce qui d'abord surpris c'était cette
espèce d'appel à tous la GRC qui est un
espèce d'aveux d'impuissance qui revient
à dire écoutez le nous autres là on
n'est pas capable de pénétrer cette
communauté là on n'est pas capable
d'avoir de renseignements aide et nous
et ça va être tout un contrat parce que
si personne a été capable de le faire
jusqu'à présent je doute que ça qui est
beaucoup de gens qui lèvent la main là
pour aller informer la GRC et je
comprends les Chinois c'est pas des gens
qui badinent beaucoup là alors quelqu'un
qui a de la famille en Chine qui est
clair que
ça risque d'avoir des répercussions
maintenant
on le sait ça que depuis longtemps là
qui a des postes mais la question c'est
de savoir comment on fait comment on
gère ça
me souviens il y a un certain temps
Madame jolie avec confronté le ministre
des affaires étrangères de la Chine et
je pense qu'il lui avait rayonné ni plus
ni moins c'est pas on a comment dire
c'est pas parce que la viennent dit
qu'il faut pas se mêler des affaires
internes d'un pays que les Chinois vont
gêner ouais Chantal
Joly était ministre conservatrice il lui
aurait dit on est de la même façon c'est
pas une question de gouvernement libéral
qui est
l'approche actuelle de la du régime
chinois vis-à-vis les pays occidentaux
et c'est pas seulement le Canada sauf
que le Canada faisant pas vraiment le
poids c'est intéressant d'ailleurs
là-dessus cet après-midi en comité
madame Joly qui témoignait se faisait
demander combien vous avez mis de
diplomates à la porte depuis X années et
rappeler en passant que quand on met des
diplômés chinois à la porte on risque de
se retrouver avec des mailles codes en
prison
c'est arrivé là c'est pas de la fiction
d'espionnage cela dit je note que tout à
coup la GRC est très très prête à aller
sur la place publique avec des enquêtes
c'est pas les habitudes la maison je
note aussi que le globalement à partir
de source gouvernementales nous apprend
qu'on a effectivement refusé un visa
diplomatique à un envoyé de la Chine à
Ottawa et j'en conclu que le
gouvernement a décidé qu'il voulait que
le plus de pro-action se retrouve dans
la sphère publique et que ça fait partie
de la guerre de Meaux à laquelle on
assiste à Ottawa montrer que le Canada
peut avoir des dents là puis dites le
parler leur dites leur Michel C
oui il faut montrer qu'on a des dalles
il faut il faut dire voici où ils sont
ces postes de police la première des
choses à dire c'est les passions
toujours un couvert de société
d'entraide à la communauté chinoise etc
et faire exploser la couverture ça se
correct mais ça le problème reste entier
après ça
il y a une communauté qui effectivement
difficile à pénétrer qui effectivement a
beaucoup beaucoup de liens avec Pékin
beaucoup plus que d'autres communautés
ont bien avec la mère patrie d'habitude
et
le Canada et pas toujours pris au
sérieux ces choses-là on était payé de
G7 on fait pas on fait pas le poids et
là il y a des choses qu'on pourrait
faire le registre des agents étrangers
comme en Australie par exemple d'avoir
une commission
demain matin il y a des choses qu'il
faut faire maintenant aussi pour montrer
notre sérieux et ça actuellement le
gouvernement répond pas à ça pour
l'instant mais le registre a été annoncé
mais je vais vous après je vais vous
reparler de ça là je vais vous je vais
faire un retour au début de semaine sur
les mesures annoncées par Monsieur
Trudeau puis le rapporteur etc mais je
vous fais entendre le chanteur en a
parlé devant ce comité sur l'ingérence
étrangère madame Joly à qui on demande
combien avez-vous expulsé puis on écoute
on voit déjà
pour 2021 combien de diplomates ont été
expulsés vous savez lorsque on peut
prévenir plutôt que guérir alors ce
qu'on a fait et c'est même dans les
nouvelles ce matin on a fait en sorte de
refuser des visas à des
questions pour
ça donne un peu le ton c'est ce que je
chantais à l'expliquer retour de table
Michel C je commence avec vous Madame
Joly dit on a refusé un ce que le globe
disait mais expulsé là c'est un jeu qui
peut être dangereux aussi
quelqu'un parce qu'on a des soupçons
c'est une chose les Chinois elles font
aussi
expulsé c'est quelque chose c'est
d'abord il y a la preuve qui vient avec
ça il faut il faut donner des signaux
d'épreuves au moins des indications au
canadiens de pourquoi on expulse puis
d'autre part ce qui va arriver
inévitablement parce que c'est toujours
comme ça il va être expulsion diplomate
canadien un moment donné est-ce qu'on
peut avoir une ambassade à quelqu'un qui
fonctionne ou si on veut avoir
un bureau qui je pourrais y aller ça
aussi c'est important c'est toujours là
on est dans la guerre froide mais
c'était comme ça que ça se passait ça se
passe encore comme ça qui quelqu'un
excuse il va de l'expulsion de l'autre
côté aussi
alors pour ceux qu'on a on a on marche
toujours sur le fait de faire dans ces
choses-là il faut être sûr qu'on a des
bonnes preuve évidemment c'est ça parce
que Chantal vous le disiez un peu et
Michel la tentation de faire des
barreaux puis de de s'emporter dire oui
oui on va expulser 53 personnes
c'est c'est
plus délicat il y a une grosse partie de
ce qu'on voit dans le moment qui est pas
consommation au Canada c'est-à-dire
essayer de rassurer conforter l'opinion
publique canadien dans l'impression que
le gouvernement est pas en train de
dormir au gaz et le gouvernement est
clairement en mode rattrapage cela dit
il y a des réalités que même si on a la
tête dans la bulle on peut pas changer
et le fêter que nous sommes
pas de la même taille que la Chine et
mais Michel a raison à la limite après
ce qu'on a vécu avec les deux manchots
se faire expulser c'est presque un
moindre mal
mais il y a beaucoup de citoyens
canadiens qui travaillent en Chine et
qui sont donc vulnérables à ce que ça
dégénère et qui deviennent les boucs
émissaires de cette
dégradation des relations Michel un mot
j'ai eu l'impression que si ça continue
le tout toute cette histoire là que le
gouvernement entre deux va être obligé
de faire un geste
démontré au moins que ils essaient de
répliquer et c'est vrai les deux Michael
mais ça ça suivait toute l'histoire de
Huawei puis de Madame
j'oublie son nom le café
alors il est pas dit que parce qu'on
expulse un diplomate il y a des civils
Canadiens qui vont être emprisonnés et
je pense que si ça continue comme ça
gouvernement Trudeau va se sentir obligé
de donner au moins l'impression que ils
sont pas complètement impuissants bon là
petit dérapage à ce comité
j'ouvre une parenthèse parce qu'après ça
je vais revenir sur l'ensemble de
l'oeuvre cette semaine est-ce que la
question que je vous posais c'est est-ce
que Justin Trudeau son gouvernement
réussi à colmater ce sentiment de
ce brides confiance envers le processus
démocratique plus élections ça ça va
être mais d'abord petite parenthèse à ce
comité je veux entendre ce coupeur qui
demande à la ministre jolie
vous êtes sûr vous avez intimidé le
chinois vous puis écoutez la suite
on accepte
on dit que ce sont des micro-agressions
sauf que si vous êtes la victime c'est
rien c'est tout autre affaire que micro
bon un petit mot là-dessus là Chantal
est-ce que est-ce que de laisser
entendre que parce qu'elle était une
ministre femme entre a-t-il laissé ça
pouvait laisser entendre ça c'est pas
une gaffe le lendemain une journée des
femmes bravo
je suis une femme par devoir
professionnel j'ai allumé la télé pour
regarder juste à ce moment-là et j'ai
trouvé que ça condescendance déplacée
effectivement méritait d'être dénoncé
qu'il y avait laissé passer une belle
occasion de se taire d'accord Michel et
Michel absolument mais
ça change rien au fond du sujet dont on
parle c'était une gaffe il y a certains
mais il est certain aussi que le
gouvernement est sur la défensive et
bien ça va continuer bien sûr ok je
referme la parenthèse je reviens parce
que la question fondamentale comment
faire pour maintenir la relation de
confiance que les Canadiens ont
vis-à-vis le processus démocratique
c'est ça là la question fondamentale de
cette question chinoise elle est là
est-ce que Justin Trudeau avec l'annonce
les annonces depuis lundi est arrivé à
colmater les brèches Michel David je
pense pas parce que il y a deux choses
il y a le fait qu'on découvre de plus en
plus de choses mais il y a des il y a
aussi le fait que le gouvernement semble
cacher des choses et ça c'est peut-être
encore plus grave dans dans l'esprit des
gens parce que la Chine tout le monde
sait on en parlait tantôt que c'est pas
facile d'intimider ou même de comment
dire de limiter la Chine mais de pas
dire la vérité à la population c'est une
autre affaire et c'est beaucoup plus ça
là qui est l'enjeu de tout le débat au
cours des derniers jours Chantal est-ce
que Monsieur Trudeau à colmaté la brèche
si par colmater la brèche vous voulez
dire ne pas être forcé à déclencher une
enquête publique qui est un des
objectifs du gouvernement probablement
pas pourquoi parce le gouvernement est
en mode rattrapage parce que l'annonce
c'est un soi-disant rapporteur spécial
ça aurait dû avoir lieu il y a 10 jours
ou ça aurait dû venir avec un nom lundi
et là on en est à se demander est-ce que
quelqu'un qui va accepter ce mandat-là
et est-ce que la personne qui va
accepter va pouvoir préserver sa
crédibilité en résistance à l'idée d'une
enquête publique alors c'est à peu près
là qu'on en est Michel C je vous donne
la parole mais donc le rapporteur
spécial je le rappelle pour les gens qui
nous écoutent doit déterminer avec les
renseignements qu'on lui donnera puis le
Comité sur la sécurité nationale et des
petits qui ont accès à des secrets vont
avoir des choses devant eux et le
rapporteur spécial doit décider est-ce
que c'est suffisant pour demander
recommander une enquête publique
toute la semaine en répondant presque
systématiquement à côté des questions
qui étaient posées et c'est le meilleur
moyen d'avoir d'air de quelqu'un que
quelque chose à cacher
vous lui demandez est-ce que vous avez
reçu de l'argent d'un papillon pour
savoir maintenant avez-vous reçu de
l'argent dans votre association de côté
répond pas à chaque fois qu'il fait
quelque chose comme ça
à chaque fois qu'il répond à côté de la
question que tout le monde comprend que
il y a une question claire et puis là
lui répond pas il s'enfonce un peu donc
si l'objectif comme le chantage c'est
pas avoir dans quel public
il a au contraire fait monter les portes
une enquête publique à cause de son
refus de réponse
ok alors ça sera à suivre parce que
effectivement on ne sait pas qui va
accepter l'emploi puis plus on attend et
plus on a l'impression que la pression
est forte sur cette personne là qu'on va
regarder ok un mot sur au Québec la SAQ
monsieur Caire on va l'écouter dis-moi
c'est pas mon ministère alors
regardez-moi pas c'est la SAC le
problème on écoute
le projet sac clic est un projet de la
SAQ donc selon nous on n'est pas
impliqué dans ce projet-là le
développement l'élaboration du projet ma
principale préoccupation communiste
décida sécurité c'est de m'assurer que
vous ne faites pas voler votre identité
ou qu'on ne crée pas un faux compte à
votre nom ce n'est pas arrivé donc ça je
pense qu'en soit c'est une bonne
nouvelle
je rappelle quand même quelques faits
monsieur Ker a été nommé 5 fois par sa
collègue madame Guilbeau dans l'entrevue
qu'elle a donné hier matin à RDI là
c'est pas nous qui avons mis monsieur
oui la question se posait bien avant oui
monsieur Ker mais madame Guilbaud
elle-même a dit ça ça relève de mon
collègue monsieur 3-4 fois là il dit non
non moi ma tâche était de sécuriser la
porte d'entrée du système demandez
quatre pièces puis le reste c'est pas de
mes affaires qu'en pensez-vous Michel
même si le dossier théoriquement le
projet a été initié par la SAC
irresponsable du numérique et c'est pas
simplement la protection des
renseignements personnels ces points
interdit d'être un peu proactif on a
nommé un ministre responsable du
numérique précisément parce que c'est
compliqué le passage au numérique dans
l'ensemble des ministères et des
sociétés d'État alors quand monsieur
Tanguy le chef intermédiaire du Parti
libéral dit mais qu'est-ce qui fait que
est-ce que c'est quoi sa mission tout le
monde va se dire oui ça a pas de bon
sens qui s'occupe pas de ça qui pose pas
de question alors au plan politique
actuellement c'est clair qui a l'air fou
beaucoup plus que Geneviève Guilbaud
Michel
on a créé ce mystère ce ministère là
pour donner un straponté à Monsieur Ker
pour être ministre d'abord le ministère
n'existait pas il a été ministre dans le
premier mandat de la cybersécurité là on
a créé un ministère mais c'est pas comme
si c'était ministre des Finances très
occupé qui dit j'ai un budget semaine
prochaine peut-être m'occuper de ça il y
a juste ça à faire alors et dans ce
mandat c'est clair c'est écrit noir sur
blanc qu'il doit conseiller les sociétés
d'État alors dire la SAC moi je m'occupe
pas de ça c'est pas d'argent c'est pas
son mandat alors un moment donné il y a
pas beaucoup de ministres sécurité des
autres Provin je pense que j'en ai pas
trouvé alors
qu'est-ce qu'il fait c'est une très
bonne question et dans une situation
comme celle-là alors que on fait revenir
la ministre de stockhol mais puis que la
moindre des choses soit qu'il soit à
l'eau bateau ne serait-ce qu'en
l'absence de Madame Guilbaud il a pas
fait alors le problème politique il est
très grand pour Monsieur
bon ce qu'on sait c'est que les gens qui
s'occupent de ce genre de système là ont
pas besoin d'un ministre pour s'assurer
qu'on se fait pas voler notre identité
on imagine que c'est leur but dans tous
les scénarios premièrement deuxièmement
si j'étais un collègue ministériel de
Monsieur Ker ministre la santé par
exemple et que je savais qu'il s'envient
un virage numérique je me dirais bon il
faut pas trop compter sur lui il va
prendre le crédit de tout ce qui va bien
et tout ce qui va aller mal il va le
piloter dans ma cour en gros c'est ce
qui a fait
voilà et je rappelle c'est Madame
Guilbaud qui a beaucoup parlé de lui
hier parce que les gens nous disent vous
avez imaginé un rôle à Monsieur car on
n'a pas rien imaginé c'est sa collègue
qui a parlé de ok c'est terminé c'est
terminé Michel David Chantal Hébert
Michel c'est Augé merci beaucoup bonsoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI